hands up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to the very first Sparky dev
vlog sorry what are these dev logs all
about well I am making a game engine
called Sparky and this is going to be a
development log of my entire journey now
most like a bunch of the engine has
already been made right so we're not
starting from scratch or anything iPad
but basically every single Monday I'm
going to be putting out one of these
videos and all I'm going to cover is
essentially what I've done in the past
week and what I plan to do for the next
week right cuz these will be every week
so it's essentially just a way for you
guys to see what I'm doing for the
engine it's a good way for me to be able
to communicate with you guys and for you
to give feedback and suggestions and all
of that so that so we can make this
engine as good as we possibly can right
so that's that's kind of the purpose of
all of these logs alright and also it's
a great great kind of thing to look back
and and actually document your journey
throughout making something right and
also for me for me to be able to reflect
on the week and be like ah you know I
don't have that much time to do this but
I should have or maybe next week I
should do more work or you know all that
kind of stuff so I think it's a really
healthy thing to be able to UM
essentially keep a video Journal of of a
journey right which is what this is all
about so this is the Sparky engine the
first thing you need to know about the
Sparky and n' is that it's open source
it's free you can get it on github home
for search the journal for Sparky this
will be in the description below
the link to this set is so this is the
entire engine okay anything that that
has anything to do with the engine okay
such as maybe future tools or anything
like that will be in this repository
okay
so you'll be able to download it and you
can just clone it or download a zip file
do whatever it is you need to do and and
you will have all the source code okay
now a good way to just to just see
what's going on with Sparky like from
this repository if you kill if you click
on the commits you'll kind of see a log
of everything that I've committed right
so you can see that in the last week
I've done basically these three commits
right I rewrote like the input system
did a bunch of stuff this was actually
quite a quite a productive week to be
honest you can see how much work has
gone into this like if I look at these
commits like they're pretty huge as well
like this one's like 65 changed files
would like 12
and you can just see like the you know
this is pretty pretty pretty pretty
active right there's a lot of stuff here
that happens and whatnot and that's kind
of the the overview of all the commits
right so that's a great place to see
exactly what has changed and you can of
course diff the files if you click on
their school it right the globally
unique identifier right which is just
like a an ID that identifies uniquely
this commit you'll be able to see all of
this all of this stuff so this is
exactly this is all everything that's
changed in this commit and you'll be
able to kind of see all the additions
and one also I'll kind of be going
through them and showing showing you
guys like new features that I've added
and showing off like all the new fun
stuff and whatnot in the engine as the
week's go on and it should just be a
really really good time generally so
anyway back to this the issues as well
as kind of a nice place I might open
some up myself when I start working on
features and whatnot but feel free to
open up any issues here to do with like
bugs and whatnot you can see that I like
back when I was putting out like the
spiky series and whatnot this was a lot
more active and and we did actually
close quite a bunch of issue quite quite
a lot of issues and whatnot and and yeah
but anyway let's start with with this
and once check out the the solution the
repository you'll open up the solution
file which is just in here if we go back
to the code and we look at the root
directory they'll be Sparky dot SLN
which is the visual studio solution
currently we're using Visual Studio 2015
so make sure you have that you can get
Visual Studio 2015
community for free of course but that's
what I'm using right now but the idea is
that I'm probably not gonna give you
guys a tour of this entire I think it'll
take way too long but basically in a
solution we've got like dependencies
which are all the dependencies these are
projects that contain code that isn't
mine right just essentially libraries
that I'm using right so you can see like
these to adjust our audio codecs and
like gorilla audio is our cross-platform
audio thing which actually compiles into
a DLL which is sp audio dot DL right and
SP just answer Sparky
right it's like a shortened version of
Sparky so we don't have to write Sparky
everywhere you'll see this all
throughout the engine
Espie just means Sparky right that's
like the the code name normally the card
name but like the like the initials
right it's just the shortened version so
that compiles into that and this is
nicely cross-platform gorilla audio just
uses like X audio or open al in fact
right now it's using open al even on
windows but anyway that's like our audio
stuff you can see 60% of our
dependencies are audio which is yeah
then we've got freetype which actually
includes for both free type and free
type GL and free type of courses is for
font rendering so essentially all the
free to type dials as it takes in font
files right like TTF files and and all
it does is it it reads them and it
rasterizes them right so it writ like
rates all the glyphs and all the
mathematical equations for all those
vector graphics and just rasterizes them
into a bunch of pixels and then free
type GL takes those pixels and uploads
them into OpenGL and packs them into a
texture for us so this is all about
texture packing in one on and all that
kind of gets converted into SP font tol
and then we've also got box duty which
is our physics library for 2d stuff this
is not actually used anywhere in the
engine yet haven't got around to that
yet but you can see that that just
composes the static library for now and
it does all the stuff compiled like if I
build it in one auto I'll be fine but um
it's it's just not you know that
particular one isn't used yet but those
are kind of our dependencies under
examples we've got like churn aircraft
which is like a little Mycroft clone
that I made but this is like the Sparky
version of it the Sparky port the reason
that's unavailable and I've kind of
unloaded that project is because like it
it doesn't work anymore because I broke
the API of Sparky so this was something
added like ages ago a couple months ago
a few months ago in fact just to test
out how that would kind of function on
this barking Sparky has develops like
probably twice as much since then so
doesn't really apply and I'm not sure I
want to have examples here examples were
supposed to be for stuff like just like
kind of mini kind of games that I made
in that I made with Sparky and that
would be good for you to look at to see
how certain things are made and how like
I intend Sparky to be used right but um
all that stuff doesn't really matter too
much here right which is why I might
actually remove that so that's kind of
the idea in fact I've got a modified
version of this so let me quickly just
revert all my changes funny story
I'm actually recording this this log
just earlier and some reason the audio
was terrible and I asked you guys on
Twitter whether or not I should re
record it and and you guys said no but I
did anyway because I you know only the
best quality for you guys so I'll have
to revert all my changes so that we
don't see what else I will demonstrate
in this video anyway that was that's
kind of a bit of a teaser if you read
any of the code there not that it was
you know particularly revealing but
anyway I think that examples might
belong in actual like a in a different
repository basically in a different
solution because I imagine that there
might be like ten of them or something
and I don't want that to be part of the
main Sparky core solution so I might
actually end up removing that sandbox is
like our testing kind of ground there's
like a playground right this is what we
use to actually like set up the engine
and test it as if it was a game so
sandbox is basically like a game in fact
if you look at the the properties for
sandbox for example you'll see that well
first of all I can pass one exe but
second of all you know there's nothing
special here and like the directories or
in like the linker or anything like that
right the only thing that it really does
is it references this Sparky call
project which we'll get to in a minute
these two yeah so you in like in sandbox
you'll see like a bunch of tests like
this test three for example which is
actually like if I run Sparky if I just
hit it at five sandbox is what opens
right it's set up it's set up as our
song as our startup project so if we
open it if we run this and like a bit of
time to compile for some reason that's
because I yeah because I reverted the
binaries lols okay
so you can see here that this is like
this test 3d for example it's something
that we're looking at right now okay
anyway that's what we see here in the in
the actual sandbox project just like
little tests and it's it's like it's you
know it's it's like a game that we used
to kind of just kind of quote unquote
game that we used to test the engine
basically while we're developing it
sandbox CS and sandbox the alive both
unload it as well because I don't really
apply anymore
so basically sandbox es was basically
like sandbox but C show up right instead
of C++ and then the CLI was the bridge
between it was essentially all the CLI
code between the Spock eco and between
this a bus boss engine and the C Schaaf
sandbox right the reason that's I've
stopped maintaining about ages ago
because it's absolutely unreasonable to
maintain like a wrapper for all the C++
classes because there are a lot in
Sparky right and in fact in any project
really so what I started doing was I
started kind of writing my own tool
which automatically wrapped all of this
stuff right and I called it like Sparky
CLI general CLI wrapper or something
like that but I haven't finished it yet
so basically what that would do is it
would basically look through all the
source files in the engine and it would
like take all the classes and all the
methods and it would like basically wrap
them in this kind of CLI land right and
so that we could use it in c-sharp
right it would just use something like
clang for example to to pass
oldest a-plus-plus files and all the
source code so that it could extract all
the you know classes methods all that
stuff
and we need that so that we can actually
use that's pretty much the best way to
be able to access if I suppose from say
sharp right so that we get like all the
objects kind of remain and we can still
use them as objects and all that stuff
so if we like to take a look at um out
what we had here I think yeah we didn't
get really far because I got I started
wrapping everything and I was like it is
gonna take way too long so I kind of
just said you know what I'll just write
at all because every time the API
changes alright at any time we add
things we'll need to maintain this
wrapping thing which is this a life
project which would be awful we want to
all happen automatically but anyway this
say shop sandbox can see at like
literally just made a new window and
like I just printed out the mouse
position that's right and that was like
it so it really wasn't too exciting but
that's kind of what happened and that
really should get removed I I don't
really want to remove it but I just my
T's need the CLI thing to be
automatically generated so we'll see
what happens with that the reason I want
c-sharp by the way is for a few reasons
first of all all
tools that are going to be Sparky right
all the older Sparky tools will be
written in C sharp because um well yeah
it's just you know like especially the
GUI tools like to like the level editor
for example that'll all be written in C
sharp and probably WPF for all the GUI
applications right and since they want
to be able to use Sparky cause since
they want to be able to use the engine
they need a link to the C++ code which
is why we need this this CLI situation
but also it's good if you just want to
test something like for example if I
only like test a new shader or something
or like an effect or I just want to put
together a quick game to demonstrate
something right doing it in c-sharp is
gonna be a lot quicker and easier than
C++ which is why it's really important
to have something like that set up and I
really want to do that but I just need
to finish the tool and I'll probably
import all everything I've done on the
tool so far you can do this I think I
might have like another folder here or
something called like tools or something
for all of the engine tools anyway
that's that's that that's basically all
that now Sparky chord the meat of
everything this is the actual engine
this is the core right the first thing
you'll see here is a to-do list huh this
is this is a good place actually this is
a good thing for you guys to look at so
that you can see roughly what I'm
working on kind of or what I should be
working on right any time I'm working on
Sparky and I kind of see something and
I'm like yeah this needs to be done I'll
probably pop it to this list and this
list is kind of you know in a semi
correct order from like should do ASAP -
not really
and this stuff it this stuff doesn't
really include major features but nor
does it really include minor kind of one
line code fixes because usually I'll
just leave a - to comment on that line
of code or something like that this is
kind of like you know not too small but
not too large things that I should do
right so stuff like some of this stuff
is pretty trivial and pretty easy to do
like for example you know adding map
three support for matrix for 3x3
matrices that's pretty easy you know
that just involves making like maths
class and there's like harder and more
difficult things like for example custom
allocators and whatnot and those are
kind of large tasks right but
this is a nice list to kind of follow to
see what we what we're doing basically
okay cool so let's move on inside here
we have the source folder and I've said
this to view like I've set Sparky
quarter view to show all file so this is
going to mimic the directory structure
on Windows the first thing you'll see
inside the source is this Sparky dot H
header file this isn't actually part of
the engine everything is part of the
engine is inside sp right Sparky but
this is actually a header file which
contains every single other header file
in the in the engine right so it
everything should be here now not
everything is because I don't maintain
this as well as I probably should like
for example none of the UI stuff that
I've added recently is in here at all
but basically this is first of all a
good way to see basically all the kind
of header files that are in the engine
right but also it's great because if we
go to something like test 3d something
that isn't part of Sparky like a game
for example all that has to do is
include Sparky donation suddenly it's
got it's got the full engine which is
awesome all right cool so that's that
stuff and yeah I should maintain that
better of course but that's the way that
that is inside the SP directory we've
got you know we've got what do we begin
what stuff like string so the way that
this is set up by the way is that
namespaces kind of reflect folders in a
way not like roughly right not it's not
always the case but it kind of is so you
can see that if we're just in this SP
folder and stuff like string is here
it's just under the SP namespace if we
go into something like audio and we look
at sound it's in SP it's in like SP
audio right like it folders this it
fault it follows this this folder
structure not always though stuff like
app everything in an app doesn't
actually belong in the app namespace
it's just kind of in the SP namespace
like Windows is as well and so is like
input right so it doesn't like app is
probably the one of the things that
doesn't apply but yeah mostly though it
kind of is right so that's kind of the
way that that works and then this string
stuff that we have right now there are a
few things that you should know about
Sparky in terms of like types and
whatnot if you look at the type set of
file for declarations that I never got
around to actually doing but they
two are important so the we've only got
three type def since Sparky I'm pretty
sure for actual like global types right
and that is Anton Charles of bytes so
basically if we refer to whenever we
refer in the engine two bytes right
we're referring to an Sun chars which is
pretty standard and unsigned in such as
typed as au int and they were used
everywhere in the engine is you and just
for convenience okay but anytime we're
doing by related stuff they'll be called
bites and bites as you can see just on
time chars and that's also kind of for
convenience right and also because it
makes more sense like to be like this is
a byte of data right across platform and
whatnot may need to redefine some of
these I don't expect it will especially
not now not in this day and age but
either way this is all this could be all
modify don't why not then we've got our
common so common doesn't actually
include anything you can see it's just a
bunch of definitions really so we've got
stuff like warnings that we want to
disable we've got we've got like you
know defines for stuff like SP API and
whatnot because this whole thing
composite to a deal well I'm probably
not gonna waste too much time going over
this because I can say that we're
already at like 17 minutes or something
and this I was gonna I kinda want to
keep these dev logs to around 20 minutes
long so I don't really want to give you
guys a full engine tour right now but if
you guys would like me to put up a video
where I go through like every single
file and every single like nitpicky kind
of project set up kind of properties
thing and explain everything then just
leave a comment below and maybe I'll
make like one long like an hour video
because it's gonna take like an hour for
me to go through all this I mean I'm
barely really started this stuff look at
like if you go to graphics especially
like the amount of stuff is in here it's
pretty crazy so if you guys want me to
do like you know a kind of this pocket
grand tour then they just leave a
comment below and and I will if if you
guys want me to do it I'll make a video
just covering all this stuff in detail
but basically yeah we've just got a
bunch of defines here like SP API and
and stuff like just a bit kind of thing
this is usually used for like enums and
I'm wondering when you're defining
values so that you can kind of create a
bit field and then this stuff is used
for like you know binding methods
essentially uh specifically binding
member functions rights and methods that
belong to a specific instance and aren't
static because it's like these these
super owners are always gonna be the
same so it's kind of just an easier way
of doing that especially if you only got
one parameter like in this case anyway
this is all that kind of stuff and then
we've got the SP dot H which is the
precompiled header just a bunch of stuff
here not really things that are in
Sparky a few things yes but not really
Sparky stuff just other stuff like STL
and like a bunch of kind of library
stuff that we continually reuse and then
SP dot cpp is the actual bringing vault
header and whatnot yeah so this stuff is
kind of set up this way again I'm not
gonna go over this now leave a comment
below if you want the tour video and I
will explain everything so this is kind
of the first dev vlog so I'm also kind
of at a loss as to what I should cover
because I kind of can't be like this is
what I did over the last week because
there was no deadlock before this one so
it's like well what did I you know I
kind of want to cover everything that
Sparky is but it on the other hand it's
like I don't want to make it our video
so yeah I probably will make that that -
a video that you guys should watch as
well because that'll cover everything
that Sparky is in detail and a lot of
this stuff will make more sense
especially for week two I think
anyway let's roughly cover what I did
this week and we'll go from there so the
big thing that I did if we go to test 3d
I've kind of been working in test three
the big thing that I did was I made
something let's close all but this if we
look at test 3d first of all this is
just like a simple test there are two
tests currently in Sparky by the way if
we go into a lot of people also asked me
how to make games with Sparky right and
whilst I don't really want to put out a
video like immediately being like this
how you make games because there is no
kind of been putting off doing that is
because the API is changing all the time
right we're so early in development here
that I check I break Sparky's API
continually okay because of that if I
put out a video telling you guys how to
make a game it will be
completely just invalid right in a week
or like in a month probably not a week
but like in a month right so there's
really no point of me doing that however
if you are really keen to get into
Sparky and start using it and start
making games with it and maybe even
start reporting bugs with it and all
that stuff then you can take a look at
sandbox because sandbox is a great
project that is essentially made for
this right it shows you how its kind of
set up there the desert sandbox or CBP
file which has the main method you can
see that it just makes a game class
instance and the game class is right in
there as well so all you do is you make
a class which extends application which
is a Sparky application you you know you
give it like you call the constructor
with like a title and width and height
you mean at the application this could
probably be done implicitly as well I
should really change that and then like
you push a layer in on to like the layer
stack and then what happens is that
layout will test 3d you can see it's
like it's a 3d layer it's a layer 3d and
and that has all your kind of event
stuff and render stuff and whatnot you
can add stuff to the layer as well
really easily and it just works pretty
well and you can see that like 3d layers
you know typically have like a renderer
and like a scene for example and there's
all this kind of setup so you can see
there's we also got one more layer
apart from that kind of cube plane thing
that you saw there's also the test layer
which is just kind of this stuff and you
can see that we've actually got we can
toggle between rendering to a texture
rendering to the screen and we can also
enable stuff like post effects which is
one of the reasons you probably want to
render to a buffer for example so go
that stuff is just a simple horizontal
blur here and then I think we can
probably just play both of them at the
same time as well so this is an overlay
versus a layer again you wouldn't know
that if you watch the two a video which
doesn't exist yet yeah you can just play
both of them the same time as you can
see and we can blur and why not
I smell that's pretty good and you can
do stuff like that so we'll just comment
out the test the test layer which is
just a 2d layer if you look at it by the
way it's just just a 2d layer so we've
got like a 2d test which is Tesla I'm
about like a 3d test which is kind of
what I'm focusing on since I'm kind of
developing 3d stuff right now for the
engine so if we look at this in detail
let's cover what I did okay in fact if
we open
this and we look at the good myths then
we can see that basically I rewrote the
emphasis this was actually a while back
as well like six days ago I did a bunch
of stuff here yeah just some graphical
stuff and whatnot fund manager API
changed that in fact I think that all I
did there was just add yeah well these
commits a huge you can see how active
this is pretty active which is why I
want to do these deadlocks
here we go hmm so the font manager stuff
yeah like I added the ability to get
fonts based on like size alone so you
could request a font of a specific size
in fact I'm pretty sure I use that here
whereabouts do I use that I would have
used Evan like the debug stuff that I'm
about to show you guys so anyway
basically I'm focusing quite a bit on
debugging things right basically debug
tools like for the engine right so
inside the engine is pretty it's pretty
typical of when we're developing a game
or the engine or you know usually I
guess if you're just developing a game
you want to be able to adjust certain
parameters in the game kind of on the
fly you don't want to have to you know
you know like I don't know recompile
your code with like a bunch of changes
or whatnot you just want to be able to
have like a little user interface which
you can use to tweak certain values for
example like oh this cube right it'd be
great if I could control its x position
or something like that
now of course you could do something
like bind a bunch of keys on the
keyboard to control that but that's
never fun like that's never really
that's that's quite a difficult way of
doing things and it takes a lot of time
you just want a really quick way to be
like hey I want to be able to modify
this value this one value or whatever
once like while the game's running so
that's that's a pretty that's a pretty
typical thing the games like to do right
so there are a few solutions to this you
could do something such as make like a
console right so you could like a lot of
games do this you can hit like the tilde
key or the back tech key and it'll open
a lot like a little console and you can
type like commands in right and you can
set like certain values and whatnot and
that's fine I personally feel like it's
a little bit awkward to use and just not
as like efficient so what I opted in for
doing is basically making something
called
like a debug menu right and this debug
menu is just like it's like a menu
filled with items that you can kind of
control right and in fact it might be if
I show you so if you hit control tab you
can see that this kind of menu pops up
and this is very early days right
I only haven't decided this like this
week basically or last week I've been
working on this for like a week so far
so it's very very early days but you can
see we've got like these these menu
items here and what we can do is it's
really easy to add stuff to this all you
have to do is in fact it says it's like
one line of code you can see this cube X
thing which controls the X transform for
this for this cube that's it that one
line of code right so we basically just
add it to the debug menu we give it a
name we set a memory address for what
like the value is that we want to modify
in this case is X transform and then of
course X transform on like in the on
update method just gets like set into
the translation kind of thing right and
then we but instead of us having to
constantly like change that we can just
kind of add it to the debug menu and
then we can change it while the game's
running so the way this works is once
you open up the debug menu you just
click on this you can see it brings up
this slider and I've set a range for it
as well negative 20 to positive 20 and
then all I have to do is click and drag
on this and how cool is that you can see
the cube moves right
pretty cool stuff so you can just like
you can see how this cube kind of kind
of moves I have the x coordinate changes
right and there's other stuff here like
font sizes just like for the actual
debug menu itself so you can change like
the font size you can change the padding
of the debug menu so if we restart it
here you can see how that works if I put
up like 2 and restart it we can kind of
you know have padding or not so there's
a few parameters here that I've course
will tweak but you can see kind of how
that works right we can just add
something and tweak it which is really
cool and the idea for this is that you
want to be able to do this from anywhere
in the code right so when you're making
a game you want to be able to just be
like hey I want to add this value into
the debug menu and then I can play
around with it just here which is yeah
really cool stuff the reason I added
this stuff as well as because I'm doing
like 3d graphics work right now so you
can
I've started with this like 3d scene and
whatnot and I'm gonna I'm just about to
do stuff like lighting and like you know
entity systems and whatnot and like
scenes and like in even like physically
based rendering and like the third
rendering and all these massive things
that require a lot of tweaking so having
like a menu like this where you can
tweak stuff on the fly is really really
useful okay
in fact debugging tools in general are
just really useful a lot of people
neglect them but I love working on
debugging tools because it's just so
important right it's really important a
lot of times when I'm working on a
problem I'll set up an environment like
to debug it better first before actually
attempt to you know you know continue
solving the problem because it's just
it's makes your life so much easier and
and it even helps you like not you know
it helps you avoid bugs and whatnot
because you can kind of you can test a
little wide range of cases really
quickly and whatnot but anyway that's
kind of the way that works right this
scene setup itself is just you can see
its got like a Maya style camera where
like if you hold down alt in you you
press down on the on the left mouse
button you can rotate and if you hold
alt and then press the middle mouse
button you can um you can pan and then
the right mouse button and alt will be
zoom right just like Maya so you can
kind of see how that works and that is
essentially the test 3d the kind of
situation right
so with debug venues in mind I had to
when I was making it as well one of the
things that I wanted to do was obviously
this stuff required like a lot of Connie
you i rewired like buttons and one on so
I decided to actually make like this and
something being printed there anyway I
decided to make like a whole UI
framework because Sparky didn't have any
kind of UI stuff before so so I went
ahead and did that and you can see
basically all that I did in some
graphics and then UI right so all this
kind of stuff we have like a panel where
we add things to and like we have like
buttons and one like you can see this is
kind of all the stuff that I've done and
then we have like a slider and widget is
like widget is like a UI control which
just has everything anyway I might go
over this in
the engine to a video but um I ended up
doing that because I wanted to do it
properly you know and the deal up menu
is basically just one big chunk of UI so
um so this this is like a button right
and then this is a slider and whatnot
and generally it works quite well and
I'm pretty happy with it but anyway
let's take a look at some some other
things so one usage of the day of the
debug menu for example would be like
let's say if we open our shader our
scene Schaller shaders in Spokeo are all
in one file by the way it's like vertex
fragment any other kind of shaders
they're all in one file that's another
thing I probably will cover in the
engine up and the engine to our video
but if we make like a uniform called
like intensity or something and we
multiply our color by the intensity
right if we would have set that so if we
go something like material dot set
uniform so we called it you intensity
and we called let's just set it to like
let's make a intensity 1.0 so if we set
that up well that's quite quickly
intensity if we just set that up and we
run it we shouldn't see any change right
because nothing's really changed yeah
but if we take it down to like 0.2 or
something yeah we should see it be quite
dark right so I want to tweak that right
so how do I add it to the how do I add
it to the debug menu and how do I tweak
it in one line well glad you asked it's
really simple all you have to do is say
debug menu and you can see it's all
static as well so you can do it anywhere
in the code you you give it a name with
such as intensity will give it the
memory address of a value so intensity
and then will give it a range maybe like
zero to like four or something is
probably a good range right and then
this set uniform of course will have to
will have to put into like you know on
top date or something so maybe I'll just
leave it over here in fact we'll have to
take out this material
there we go okay so if we check that out
you can see that if I grab this and one
more you can see it's a 2.2 I can kind
of change it as you can see on the fly
how cool is that well it's very bright
so you can see how you can kind of tweak
stuff like that on the fly and like in
this case it's affecting the entire
scene because you can see that all of
these components there's like sphere and
the cube and the plane and the ground
plane they they all use they're all
based on this one material right which
is the shader and I'm modifying the
entire materials uniform so what I could
do instead if I want to adjust the cube
for example is I could use the material
instance instead so if I had you know
I'll call it like cube material and then
I'll bring back our original material
and then I'll make sure that the cube
material cube material is of course that
right so I've just refactored that and
then we'll take it and we'll only apply
the uniform to the cube material and we
run that then well that's why
everything's going to be black I just
realized because I didn't set the
uniform for all the other objects right
so we'll set intensity equal to you know
just like 1 or something for all the
other ones then you can see that just
the cube is that intensity yeah
you can see you can kind of control that
using that slider so pretty cool stuff
I really like the debye menu it's a
really cool kind of thing to have around
I'll pray I'll extend it a lot like for
example one of the problems right now is
that if I add a like if I changed this
to be intensity intensity or something
like like a long string you'll see that
this actually just spills out right
because I'm just you know the the width
is fixed right now what I should be
doing obviously if we had font metrics
in the engine which is actually on the
to-do list for metrics we'd be able to
measure you know the length of the
largest string and then set that to be
the width like the largest like string
in the in the in the entire like
you and then set that to be the width
and we would do something like that
right so I will do that infusion we'll
probably also have stuff like
directories right so it's like folders
inside the debug menu so you can specify
something like you know cubes like slash
intensity and you'll be able to go into
that if you certain properties because
once we add a million things to this
it's gonna be very long and we probably
want you know the ability to scroll and
there's just all this stuff that needs
to be added to this but overall I think
it's a pretty cool little menu to have
in the engine and right now it works
pretty well so yeah anyway ah that's
pretty much it hope you guys enjoyed
this dev vlog so how can you stay up to
date with Sparky happy new guys be more
involved in Sparky well first of all
I've actually got a Trello board right
that I should talk about so if you go
over to essentially if you just go to
like my open Google it's just like it's
literally just a bit dot Lee slash
Sparky trailer right if you go to this
URL link will be in the description it
will take you to this page right to this
trailer board and this is a good way to
see kind of what I'm working on right
and you guys can leave comments and one
on here I might have to adjust my
permissions or something but you guys
can leave kind of comments here and I'll
be kinda I was gonna go through this
lesson and triage it but this dev vlog
is just so long we might do that next
week anyway umm and you guys can see
kind of what I'm working on what kind of
I need to do and you can kind of
probably Bart on features that you want
Donnelly comments on all the features
and one on there's a lot of stuff that
you could do here which is pretty cool
so yeah I'll definitely change this
permission to public so that you guys
can make comments on all this stuff and
you can kind of see kind of how that
stuff is panning out right the github
page is also kind of important because
like I'll probably start opening issues
and whatnot there so like so that you
can follow along with that as well and
I'll probably label them and whatnot and
of course the commits is a good way to
stay up to date with what I've changed
but the best way hands down is simply to
join slack right so I've got a slack
team right and there's a there's a
channel in there called Sparky okay and
this stuff is fantastic
there's like 47 people here right you
guys can talk about how Sparky works you
know if there's something in the
engineer understand or if you have a
suggestion you can just talk to people
here there's always people here you can
see I'm always here because like
slackers literally on my phone so every
time you guys like say something I get
like a notification basically and I can
if I'm on like the the tram to work or
something on the train to work I can
just respond straight away and one on
and I'm always reading this stuff so
it's a really good place to hang out but
also right the other reason you want to
join this is because you can see that
there's actually like a there's a github
bot here yeah so this guy anytime I came
in anytime there's any activity in the
repository such as someone opens an
issue or something this guy will post
here okay so it's a really good place to
just to be out so you can essentially
see kind of what's going on with that so
um so I encourage all of you guys to
join that you can you can join that by
just going to what is it
slacked off the channel comm right and
if you go to select all the turnover
column you'll be great to put this thing
where you can enter your email address
and basically you'll get an email with
with instructions on how to join this
right really really simple and I
encourage you guys to get in here I'm
sure there'll be a lot more than 47
people here soon and yeah and I'm it's a
great place to be right the other thing
is if you guys enjoy my videos and you
want to support me more then I do have a
patreon account patreon.com 4/2 Cherno
you guys can pledge a certain amount per
month and that will essentially just
support the development of Sparky and
support me making more videos and
whatnot now in terms of Sparky you don't
really get much like you don't get
anything not none of the rewards have
anything to do with Sparky right for
like 5 bucks a month or more you get
access to like the oldest source code of
game programming but if you guys have
any ideas for any kind of Sparky rewards
let me know maybe we can work this out
and make it pretty awesome because I
don't have like I don't know I might
have to start doing like t-shirts or
something I don't know what to do really
but um I think I think some cool rewards
folk like Sparky based things would be
pretty awesome and we can kind of work
this thing out so the benefits both you
and me but anyway that's pretty much it
if you guys enjoyed this first dev vlog
make sure that you hit a like button and
leave a comment
based on your thoughts and whatnot I I
think I definitely will put out that um
I think I definitely will put out that
that to of video because there's so much
like I could go on for hours about all
this stuff is so much in here but I'm
going to be working on this engine a lot
this year the the the goal basically is
to have this game ready but I like 2017
right so by the end of the year I want
this to be game ready meaning that you
can make a 3d game with this and and a
2d game with this right which is a
pretty pretty big goal but I think I can
get there right especially with your
support so um thanks for watching guys
and I will see you guys next Monday with
the next step vlog and these this will
happen every single Monday for ever
pretty much alright guys I'll see you
later bye